knowledge is knowing that Frankenstein
wasn't the monster wisdom is knowing
that Frankenstein was the monster
hello Internet welcome to film theory
we're like the cast of Fame I'm
determined to live forever and we're
delightfully a tease legwarmers while
doing it and so in my quest for
immortality you can bet my I was drawn
to the new movie Victor Frankenstein
starring the epic duo of Charles Xavier
and Harry Potter no not that version of
Xavier there you go now when it comes to
film adaptations Frankenstein is about
as classic as it gets with films going
back over a century but many of the
things we associate with the tale of
Frankenstein actually got their start on
celluloid and not cellulose that's a
film and not paper I use the highfalutin
words for the alliterative effect that's
the type of quality writing you can
expect here in film Theory ladies and
gentlemen for example the doctors
grave-robbing started in the film neck
bolts grab your popcorn it's in the film
hunchbacked assistant film in fact in
the book he has no assistant and the
name Igor isn't mentioned once which is
a huge loss for Mary Shelley since she
totally missed out on Danny rads
adorable British accent you significant
decision you're so cute Harry Potter
weird to be saying that about a guy who
is literally the same age as me I think
does he the same age I don't even know
he's younger than me damn curse you and
your magical youth anyway digressions
aside with zombies all the rage these
days in the new movie out now it got me
thinking why don't we look at pop
culture's most famous zombie
Frankenstein's monster and the science
of bringing a human back from the dead I
mean times have changed since Mary
Shelley's book is this work of science
fiction still more fiction than science
what sort of challenges with a good
doctor face if you were to try and do
these sorts of experiments in real life
is it possible to reanimate the dead the
answer surprisingly is yes
and it may shock you to know that the
walking-dead are around you right now as
we speak I mean the real walking dead
not the TV show Carl let's start off
with harvesting organs from dead bodies
and for that we turn to the Big D no no
not quite
why are you even guessing there is no
chance that your everybody no it's not
that you're never going to get it Big D
zero two zero eight five eight the
official code for tissue and organ
harvesting is recognized by the National
Library of Medicine Earl I don't know
why you insisted on shoving all these
images onto the screen I told you there
was no chance that you would get it
I appreciate the enthusiasm though
anyway the phrase organ harvesting is a
medically recognized term with its own
official code who knew right I'm sure a
bunch of pre-med students are currently
typing in the comment section right now
that they knew well good for you guys on
that note here's a joke for you how do
you know when someone's premed don't
worry they tell you Oh shots fired
bam bam bam boo that's that's me doing
an air horn sound effect anyway the
process of harvesting working organs
from a deceased person and giving them
to living people who desperately need
them has been around for decades and
today the majority of donated organs
actually come from the deceased in fact
I myself am a registered donor so better
called dibs on my body parts before I go
I can already start to see the fights
breaking out in the comments section
over who will get my fearest spleen and
not only are transplants from the
deceased common like doctor Vick who
gathers his parts from multiple quote
unquote donors and puts them all into
one body it is indeed possible to take
organs from multiple deceased donors and
give them to a single recipient one such
case was recorded as early as 1986 where
a 12 year old girl was given a heart
from one donor and then a liver from
another but all right I know what you're
thinking I'm just talking about internal
organs Frankenstein was an amalgamation
of a bunch of limbs and limbs are a
whole different thing and your rights
kudos to you for being able to tell the
subtle difference between a leg and a
kidney but here's the thing yes they're
difficult and yes they're rare but limb
transplants do happen after a failed
hand attempt in both 1964 and 1998 the
first limb transplant to see long-term
success was performed on January 14 1999
in Louisville Kentucky a man named
Matthew Scott had lost his left hand in
a firework accident during the 80s and
had a new one attached a few short
months after his surgery he threw the
first pitch in a Philadelphia Phillies
baseball game with his new hand since
then there have been hand and arm
transplants almost every year since and
the first double leg transplant was
performed in 2011 and depending on when
you watched this literally days ago the
most extensive face transplant was
completed successfully look at us
covering topical news stories in short
limb transplants are still rare mostly
because they cost an arm and a leg
figuratively and
literally but it's deaf that was so bad
that was so bad but it's definitely not
science fiction this is a regular
procedure with a reliable success rate
so the idea of Frankenstein's monster
being stitched together from multiple
different human corpses isn't as
outlandish as it might seem but okay
we're talking about stitching limbs on
to live bodies what about what I teased
at the beginning of the episode bringing
someone back from the dead I mean in
order to perform the classic line it's
alive it's live it had to be dead to
begin with otherwise it's just kind of
redundant so is it possible to reanimate
the dead to understand that we have to
understand what actually happens to your
body when you die there are two types of
death recognized by modern medicine
well thorny if you count legal debt but
it's not like Frankenstein's monster was
trying to avoid his back taxes or skip
jury duty or anything so that one
doesn't really apply here let's just
talk about the other two brain death and
clinical death brain death is defined by
a complete and irreversible cessation of
brain function if you've ever heard of a
patient being in a persistent vegetative
state brain death is actually a couple
steps below that on the ladder patients
in a persistent vegetative state still
show some amount of brain activity their
eyes can sometimes track moving objects
they can often breathe on their own and
even swallow food unassisted between a
vegetative state and brain death is
what's called a coma comatose patients
generally don't respond to any stimulus
at all and won't be able to swallow on
their own however despite this lack of
response their brain still does show
some activity both comatose patients and
patients and persistent vegetative
states still have some chance of
progressing back to awareness and even
fully regain consciousness but a
brain-dead patient is past the point of
no return
their brain shows no activity and as a
result their heart probably won't be
able to beat on its own they are
literally being kept alive by machines
and medical staff very few brain-dead
patients are kept alive on life support
for more than a few days since it's so
expensive and there's literally no
physical way for them to ever recover
generally after a patient is declared
brain-dead the family says their
goodbyes the plug gets pulled and
clinical death begins clinical death is
defined as when the heart and lung
stop functioning usually we inhale an
oxygen enters our bloodstream and
consequently gets applied to all the
cells in our body at the same time all
our cells expel waste and other nasty
stuff and this gets carried away from us
when we exhale if we no longer supply
oxygen and nutrients to the cells then
they won't have the energy to function
and if we no longer exhale then the
cells have no place to put their waste
this means that cells lacking any energy
source begin to weaken while rapidly
accumulating all sorts of acidic wastes
that they can't get rid of eventually
their membranes wither and they explode
obviously dying in the process this is
called autologous and different cells
die at different rates
brain cells tend to be the first to go
needing only 3 minutes before they start
showing signs of damage while things
like kidneys and livers can last up to
20 minutes and muscle cells can
literally last for days this issue
becomes a huge point when doctors
harvest organs from deceased donors how
long have the donors been clinically
dead and how damaged have those organs
become because brain cells are so
fragile clinical death is usually
followed by brain death notice though
that I said usually unlike brain death
you can come back from clinical death
remember clinical death is defined by
the cessation of the body's vital
functions like heartbeat and breathing
and well yes those systems might go down
for a while with prompt enough attention
those systems can be brought back online
and here's the really crazy thing
believe it or not doctors during certain
procedures will intentionally induce
clinical death in their patients perform
the surgery and then reanimate their
patients right there in the hospital
room they are literally inducing death
in people working on them and then bring
them back to life they even use electric
shocks from defibrillators it's live
they don't shout that though that would
be really concerning I would be very
shocked if that was my doctor
defibrillators a whole lot easier than
harnessing the power of lightning bolts
so let me tell you about this procedure
for certain surgeries doctors sometimes
use what's called a hypothermic
circulatory arrest where they drain all
the blood from a patient's body and
replace it with either a saline or
potassium solution cooled down to
somewhere around 15 degrees Celsius
at this point the patient's heart stops
beating and they stop breathing they are
considered clinically dead then the
doctor performs the surgery replaces the
blood and resuscitates the patient
provided the whole thing lasts less than
a half-hour many patients are able to
survive this procedure with absolutely
no brain damage this is because when our
organs get cooled down by even a few
degrees their metabolic rate slows down
so they use less oxygen and produce less
waste which means they can go much
longer before showing signs of damage
individual organs ready for transplant
are kept cold for this very reason brain
cells can go from lasting only three
minutes to safely lasting 30 some have
even gone as long as 60 livers can be
bumped up past the 12 hour mark and
kidneys can go to something like 35
every so often you hear a news story
about a skier or a toddler being trapped
under ice for something like 40 minutes
and somehow they're able to survive and
make a full recovery without any damage
despite the fact that they didn't have
any oxygen for that entire time well
this this is why despite having your
blood drained from your body and you
being put to death it's actually a
fairly safe procedure most famously
having been performed on a pregnant
woman in 1994 when an aneurysm had
ruptured in her left lung she survived
the surgery and successfully delivered a
healthy baby a few months later let me
translate that for you that child was
dead and then brought back to life
before he was even born
that's as hardcore as you can get that's
got to be like some sort of record long
story short is all of this a
technicality on the definition of death
admittedly yes though your heart
stopping and you no longer breathing
seems like a pretty strong ruler to
measure you're living and dead against
but the biggest moral of the story here
is that as long as the brain is still
working the rest can follow good dr.
Frankenstein actually bring a patchwork
of dead body parts back to life no and
certainly not during the time period
depicted in the film but medical science
today has made it possible for dead
limbs to find new bodies and for doctors
to reanimate the dead the only missing
link now is finding a way to transplant
a living brain into a dead body oh and
we still need a nifty use for those neck
bolts but hey that's just a theory a
film the
hurry and cut like the cast of Fame I'm
determined to live forever and we're
delightfully lady ladies night warmers
wow that's a as a Freudian slip